Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina Vincent.
Yeah,
it is a,
it's a very nice jacket.
Thank you.
I,
you asked me,
well how much do you think a jacket like this cost time?
500 bucks at $30 is cool.
It's like a cheapy h and m he drag it.
That's where I get all my stuff cheap.
That shit looks fly man.
Thanks Bro.
Toes gels and my summer bomber.
Look at Joe Sam.
It looks,
uh,
it looks like a downtown flag here.
Like little little Tokyo gear.
Like I'm cool and I know where to shop stuff.
Yeah,
it does.
You know what?
I was a little afraid of real talk.
What's up?
Is that the prince floral?
I was kind of afraid of looking like a Tommy Bahama Dad.
Oh No,
it does not look like,
are you sure?
No,
cause my stepdad used to wear Tommy Bahama all the time with these horrible
prints and I'm like,
it's Kinda like,
it's a little tiny.
It doesn't like that,
I promise.
Okay,
let's do a proper show open.
And I was saying we'll get into everything.
Show me all the time now.
Very exciting,
very exciting stuff.
Here we go.
Population defense.
Here's another instance when you need to give the appearance of going along with
what is happening.
If you're being forced down to orally,
copulate your attacker and defense is simple.
Quit fighting and wait for your chance.
Then bite off his penis.
Don't bring in in loving.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
This is how I feel every time I'm forced to orally.
Copulate.
You feel like doing this to me?
No.
I just know that I have to surrender.
I had to give it.
Why?
Why do you feel like my attacker?
I'm not an attacker.
I'm your spouse.
You're always trying to trick me too.
You're like,
oh,
I'm soft.
I need help,
and then I go down there and you're like,
just kidding.
That's what Bobby likes to do to bite off his penis,
Trish.
Yeah.
Bobby is all about it.
Trish wouldn't do that though.
Just would never bite off.
No Way.
Trish lives for the Goblin Cox.
Whoa.
That's what she loves.
That's Trish.
Karen our trash.
They both are the boat down.
My favorite thing about both of them,
they're super done
love.
So low self esteem chicks,
they are the best for one for that thing for loving.
So I'm assuming that's what I hear.
Oh yeah.
I won't give away too much better marital love makings but by being Trish had a
rendezvous.
Yeah they did.
And uh,
it was funny cause I rendezvous with my triple d s l u t
came up with that one.
That was funny.
That was good.
But um,
it was funny cause I,
I had a thing I was trying to unbutton right.
And then you were,
and then,
and then you said something and you just were patient with me and I was like,
no,
Bobby wouldn't be patient.
They'll say,
oh Bobby would say,
cause you were on buttoning like this road.
It's hard to,
and you're like,
oh I'm sorry.
And I go,
you could,
what would you say right now?
I go,
okay,
just take your time.
And you're like,
no,
be Bobby.
Oh Jesus.
All right.
Rip that thing off then.
Fuck.
You were like,
yeah,
you're like,
I don't give a shit.
Rebut the tear it,
tear it off,
bitch.
Yeah.
That's really funny.
Yeah,
that is neat.
Anyways,
I went to the 99 cent store today,
which for me in eastern blocker who hates spending money.
That is like Jack.
Yeah man.
I forgot how cool it is there and how much shit there is to buy for now.
I'm not really a 99 cent guy,
but one of the thing that is great,
one thing that I have bought there before,
it's like cleaning supplies,
things,
you know,
sponges and yeah,
little whatever,
Windex,
all that kind of bullshit.
It's great.
Crazy it.
They sell it there for that much.
There's so much cool stuff there now.
It's gotten really good and they have really neat Halloween things.
I got really excited.
I lucked out so much in this,
in the spending department and the chief was all I heard about growing up.
I always go,
ah,
my wife spends money.
It's all she does and you're like,
I got this thing for two hours I thought can tell you I'm a tell you guys.
I got so excited because I saw the Halloween aisle and it was really good.
Like they have really good stuff there.
I was very surprised and I actually walked through it and I felt a Pang of
guilt,
like I shouldn't buy us.
I was kind of fancy,
you know?
And then I walked the isles and then I went back and I was like,
you know what Christina,
you can treat yourself right here.
And I spent 20 whole dollars.
Wow.
Halloween stuff.
And I,
that's a lot of stuff at the 99 cents for the 20 things is anything over 99
cents?
99 cents is a starting point.
There are some items,
the nicer ones that are a dollar 99.
Whoa.
But they're really nice.
She would never,
you're going to see the Halloween decorations I got are so nice.
Okay.
Beyonce.
So excited.
Jesus.
Anyway,
I got a lot of stuff for LJ for the airplane.
Right on Sunday,
uh,
a mom friend of mine told me to buy a bunch of shift in the 99 cent store for
him to play with on the plane.
You know what?
I'm saying I didn't get them toys.
I got him like kitchenware and shit like he likes to play with,
you know?
Yup.
And um,
they had a glow in the dark acts and I probably posted on Instagram.
I thought of you immediately.
It's like,
it's like a little evil kid with a glow in the dark acts.
Yeah,
we got that for him.
Of course.
I was like,
is this not Tom Segura his son right here,
so he could be like a little ax murderer.
Yeah.
Isn't that neat for the flight though?
Right?
Courses for the flea.
Oh really?
Well it's a glow in the dark.
I mean,
you know,
I figured why not?
I talked about it with my shrink today and well,
uh,
look,
he,
she told me,
she goes,
he's going to cry during takeoff and landing.
You should count on that because their ears are very fragile at that age.
And uh,
you know,
just,
you know that that's an inevitability.
Give him something to suck on,
like a bottle.
Right.
Milk.
Give him as Baba and uh,
you know.
Oh.
And she said the crying,
he's actually good cause that's how they unplugged their ears through crying.
It'll help the process.
So she goes,
it's actually a good thing.
And you know,
I have a big fear of losing control.
That's my thing.
I got control issues.
So for me,
the baby crying like that on.
And I also am afraid of judgment of other people.
It's not so much the freak out because he's freaked out in public before,
but it's that it's in an enclosed space.
It's heightened and we're going to ruin other people's flight.
That's my fear.
And them looking at me like this dumb fuck woman doesn't know how to take care
of her kid.
Yeah.
So what do you,
what's your biggest,
uh,
I dunno.
I mean,
talking to friends,
one of my friends was like,
well,
you know,
your kid's going to cry.
You can't worry about that stuff.
People,
people know that kids cry.
Yeah.
And they've been around kids before and you know,
if they're irritated by it,
that's just part of it.
When you do your best,
obviously to try to,
to get over it.
But yeah,
I have total anxiety about a total.
And I remembered it's similar to the anxiety.
I'm also very sensitive to that,
to others.
Other people being like,
oh my God,
I'm in a restaurant.
If he bangs,
uh,
a fork against the table,
you know,
like I'll grab him and be like,
Hey,
I don't want to bother other people.
Yeah.
I'm the same.
Um,
I had the same panic the first time I flew with fif back in the day.
Super Nervous,
so scary.
I would relax when I finally put it under the seat and his shield and I was
like,
and then I'll get anxiety if the person next to me,
can I get out?
I'd be like,
oh,
just be careful because he does a dog.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know what apologetic.
But you know what that is.
I mean,
for me anyways,
it's,
it's my perfectionism where if I'm not a perfect,
I'm not perfect at being a mom,
that I'm a piece of shit.
That's my big thing is don't like then,
then it means that I'm a bad person.
If I could help you,
uh,
get over that.
So I can some dude's dig.
Not some dude,
my friend Kevin.
If you blow him,
you'll feel better.
Who's Kevin?
I Dunno.
It's this guy.
Nice guy.
The guy.
You're a our son's real dad.
What?
You don't think LJ is your son?
I have thoughts.
I have doubts.
And what part of that?
What part of him?
You know,
you don't,
don't you think resembles you or no,
no,
no.
Sometimes I look at them and I'm like,
what was your Bio Dad?
Okay Bob.
Hey,
she's really,
this will cause shock and definitely end.
Any thoughts about rape?
Definitely.
Oof.
It's terrifying.
But it is a crazy thing.
I like his haircut though.
Look at that.
Yeah,
it's definitely eighties he's a super dad.
Let's take another look at this defense.
Oh yeah.
He's telling you to suck it.
You're pushing back.
I fucking,
well,
if you want to survive,
you'll consider this a fence technique girl,
which I mean,
is there a cucumber?
Yeah.
Or He's had a real bloody dark.
He had a really green,
dark dick.
Wow.
And they showed her biting it and he's all,
this will cause shock.
And definitely.
And any thoughts about rape?
Hell yeah,
definitely.
I don't know who wrote that.
But they deserve an award.
Yeah.
He ain't rape.
And now here you go.
Rape.
Now deck bed off your dicks off.
Didn't have,
that is a really good tactic.
I,
I mean,
if I were,
if I had the wherewithal to do it,
I definitely would in that situation to just put it in your mouth.
Right.
The fuck out of that deck,
Dude.
Yeah.
Rip His fucking nuts off too.
I wonder if Jim Ryan the Dick,
if he would then have a case against you,
you know,
feel like I was,
yeah,
I was going for it,
but like she didn't have to bite it off.
Oh,
I bite it off.
Yeah.
It's fucking,
yeah.
Nothing sounds worse than a,
than a dick bite.
No.
And then you have the dig blood in your mouth and everything.
It's not good,
but know.
Right.
And I also wonder if my veneers can handle that kind of a bike.
Oh,
right.
I mean,
I can't even buy an apple.
You'd have a hell of a dental update.
Your dentist would flip.
You're like,
what happened with like,
I bet this dude's dick off.
What?
This guy's Dick in my mouth.
[inaudible] it off.
I get pictures to show him and he's just like,
yeah,
let me put you know what's on the house today.
Don't worry about anything.
All the charges.
Do you think a lot of women forced men to go down on them?
You think that's an epidemic?
No,
I don't think so.
But it definitely has happened and continues to happen.
There's just not a lot really knew a lot to get.
You can only buy her vagina.
You gotta think about it.
There's probably
some relationships out there where the woman is a bully and even less where the
woman is stronger,
but it definitely happens.
Of course it happens,
which is amazing to think about as a guy because it's almost inconceivable to
most guys.
But it happens.
Of course.
Yeah.
She's like,
you better do this.
Better eat my pussy fucking idiot.
And he's like,
do it like this.
But then what can he do?
I guess he can try to block it.
Yeah.
Oh right.
But no,
see,
he's probably just so scared.
You could bite down there and yeah,
you could.
Ooh,
that would hurt past.
What have you been as balls?
I think that would hurt worse.
Yeah.
I think a ball bike might be more effective than a dick.
Bitey.
Yeah.
Ball bite would just shut down the whole system.
Your whole body would just shut down.
You know what I would do?
Okay.
I would,
yeah.
I would give in and then I would give him a,
I might get my dick bite and a ball pole feel good.
I feel good.
I'd like that.
I wouldn't like the Dick by it,
but I'd be like,
that ball pill.
That tug feels good.
Hug.
What if it's a full pole?
Like,
yeah,
but even that aggressive fucking Paul,
you're,
I dunno.
I would be like your like your balls licked and then you go under and be like,
ah,
and then you got high.
You bite one of those balls.
That's over.
Then all thoughts of Rapor God.
Yeah,
that's true,
right?
All thoughts of rape are gone.
He should be teaching her the ball by not just the Dick Bite.
Why don't we make a new video?
Nothing wrong with that.
Offer to lick his balls.
And then when you go in for the leg,
he forces his penis in your mouth.
Stop Him and say,
do you like having your balls?
Then place his balls in your mouth.
Spit a bunch on them so he thinks your game and then take a big bite.
Hiring
nasty.
We could make that video.
We'll use some peaches,
peaches to,
you know they had a cucumber.
Then
simulate.
Yeah.
Do you like your balls?
Licked
your attacker?
We'll pause.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Hold on.
A matter of fact,
I've never had that done before.
Could you do it real quick?
Stupid rapist.
Stupid,
dumb rapists.
How about this?
This guy's pretty much a a rapist.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Is this guy talking?
I don't know,
but I mean it's like on the subway and he tells his guy.
Let me see.
I didn't an American man.
Oh,
he was in Singapore.
Is Female friend filmed this as the,
as the Asian man reportedly kept asking him for sex.
Yeah.
I mean,
so this is older guys on the subway and he's like,
you are gay.
Are you gay?
Yeah,
I'm talking to him.
I know.
Fuck it.
This is my friend and you're being very rude.
Oh No,
no.
She's talking,
I'll find I'm your friend.
Oh yeah,
no,
I want you to fuck me.
Collect.
I don't know who you are.
I want you to fuck me to Max.
Whoa.
Wow.
Very different approach and also demanding to be fucked it.
That's also really interesting because you're being aggressive,
but you're asking for this submissive role.
Right?
I feel like I missed the introduction here.
The introduction was this,
what about Facebook?
So sorry
y'all.
Fuck
said thing about,
I see you on Facebook,
you're gay,
you're gay.
I'm gay too.
And then he's like,
I'm talking to you bitch talking to him.
Oh.
And she,
and then the boy,
the guy goes,
that's my friend.
He goes,
she,
this guy goes,
that's not your friend.
I'm your friend.
And he's like,
ah,
no,
no thanks.
I want you to fuck me in my ass.
Yeah,
I talking to him.
I know.
Fuck it.
This is my friend who you're being very rude.
Oh No,
no.
She thought your friend.
I'm your friend.
No,
you're not.
I want you to fuck me.
Collect.
I don't know who you are and I'm not in.
I want you to fuck me to Max.
Whoa.
All right.
I feel like he's just learned these phrases for his,
you know,
his pleasure.
Basically.
He doesn't speak good English,
but he's like,
how do I say this?
Oh yeah,
I want you to fuck me tonight.
Pretty good.
Pretty good at it.
Isa Lbgq I'm the IB nuts.
Yes,
you are your games.
Please leave.
Please don't touch me again.
Please don't touch.
We can patch you.
Hey,
yeah.
Now,
yeah,
he should definitely dig.
Bite this old guy I know.
Or do the ball licking approach.
Yeah.
He should be like the guy.
She'd be like,
do you want me to do,
I went to to fuck with tonight.
He should go.
Do you like having your balls lick?
And the guy's like,
what?
Yeah,
I do it.
And then he goes,
well,
they're all a lot long licks.
All his balls,
but like for like 2030 minutes.
And then Adam,
yes.
Wait.
Hi.
You mean he's sharpening his knife for that long?
Well,
you got to make it.
You got to,
you can't have him a suspect you're going to do some don't.
So you gotta kind of get into it for a long time to get your balls lick that.
Well,
I mean he's trying to convince them,
right?
Like I'm not going to do like I'm game.
That's how you lower him in.
You spit on his dick and his balls for like 25 35 45 minutes.
Right.
That's what I would do.
And then when he's like really in the euphoria of it,
then you bite his balls.
Oh,
so you really,
you're really roping him.
Yeah.
But you got to blow him and lick his balls for like an hour and a half for this
Matt,
that door.
Yes.
To work.
This is my approach.
This is how I train women all the time in this.
This is my very system that
I passed.
I don't like where this is going.
What do you mean this is problematic?
You're making fun of Ray?
No,
no,
no.
Wait a minute,
I'm talking about it.
The fence,
the fence system that I've developed over years.
Oh,
are you like the sharpening the knife guru?
Yeah.
I teach this class where I,
and I have women practice,
you know on me.
I go,
just put this in your mouth for like 30 to 40 minutes and,
and then when I least suspect that,
just show me your finger and that'll be a,
that'll be a signal that your mind or she has to put her finger in your bom hall
and then that's a surprise to get away from me.
Now sometimes what'll happen is I'll come to turn it during that time period and
then I go,
now we've got to start over.
But you know,
we're getting there.
It's just,
it's a matter of practice,
practice,
practice.
Every time I see Asian guys now,
I always assume they're showing like,
oh,
we went to a Sushi bar yesterday and little Tokyo to our old stomping grounds
around there.
And all the Sushi chefs.
I just imagined them sharpening their knives before their shifts,
you know?
Do you think he's sharpening his knife this morning?
Like a hundred percent he did rob.
So stupid.
I don't do all Asian men do that.
That's crazy.
Rob,
rob,
all of them because of that one guy,
he ruined aging men for us forever.
That's great.
I become racist now.
There was no racist.
You're just assuming that all these guys come hard.
You're not wrong.
Invisibly come,
I think to me right there,
he tries,
they're contracting their tech guy.
If they're not circumscribed to circumstances,
not all guys are circumstances.
And then they,
uh,
pull the skin back and you just Jack Your Dick.
So many people,
by the way,
I never thought this,
but a lot of people messaged when I tweeted out the link to that video.
They're like,
this guy's mentally ill.
Most people are that we air on this shit.
Well,
mental illness,
video show.
No,
it's not.
It's are you crazy?
Come to your mom's out.
No,
that goes a bit funny.
But he's not crazy.
He's a very deliberate system.
The same way I do with my self defense class.
Right?
Sure.
Crazy.
Wonderful.
Wow.
This lady is trying to tell him,
I believe she put her hands on him like that.
Not that she's wrong,
but just that that's a bold move.
But I,
you're right.
You're absolutely right.
However,
to be cleared so we,
the audience understands this listening.
Uh,
another third party came in,
a woman,
American woman came in and put her hands on the Asian man and like told him to
calm down and get back.
But see,
in our world and the female world,
a gay man,
it is equal to a woman.
Oh,
we don't think of them as dudes.
I think they're just,
they're girls like us.
They're cheeses.
That is so offensive.
Know it's true though.
I'm going to weep.
No,
but don't you think?
But see,
that guy actually took to it.
Okay.
He was like,
look,
he says giving it to her,
but I can't believe he didn't push her back cause he was touching the other
people.
That's not cool.
Why would Yoshi demand sex from another space on the train like that?
Isn't that Yoshi?
Come on.
Could it be him older Yoshi?
Although Yo,
she's like 50 now and he looks like he's 20.
It's horrible.
Is that possible?
I know it's not fair.
He looks really good.
Sorry.
So yeah,
so just to be clear now,
the Asian man is saying there's no laws here.
Anyone can touch anybody,
which I doubt is true in Singapore of all places.
That is super strict.
Um,
and then she's like,
he's a gay,
I'm a gay.
Did this happen to you when you were in Singapore?
No.
No,
no.
You know what I do like about,
um,
the older gays like this?
Like he really does put it out there.
Like the flag is flying and he's like,
look man,
I want to fuck.
But at this age,
I,
I applaud that.
You shouldn't be like that.
I agree.
Good for you.
I don't like these harassing this,
this dude.
I don't think that's something that bothered,
but
let's see if he actually,
Mister Roper,
uh,
Asian.
Mr. Rowe closed the deal here.
What's your fucking face off?
He's drunk,
right?
Whoa.
Nuts.
They're world is fucking know.
But who,
who connected there?
Did he connect with the guy?
He had the guy that he's trying to get to fuck him.
Wow.
That was,
he slapped that guy's face.
I think
he's holding his face.
Just hit me.
That's what a Dick head.
Fuck.
This
sexual assault episode.
What's going on?
And it comes together.
I want you to fuck me too.
Like
what's with all the assault clip,
whereas our other guy,
right?
One is a humble request.
The other one is a demand.
Keith,
you
fucking gave fucking gay.
Yes.
You all.
Y'all gates.
He just told that dude he was,
that guy.
Didn't say anything to him.
Our thing is real man,
but who knows if that guy really was,
who knows?
Yeah.
I don't know his female friend companion,
you know?
But I guess she didn't say this is like my boyfriend,
my husband still.
That guy's crazy.
So good luck to him.
I hope things work out well.
Anyway,
we were in Red Tokyo yesterday and we met him.
Mommy on the street.
That was fun.
Yeah,
that was pretty cool.
I was like,
hey mommy's,
I'm like,
whoa.
Walking across the street.
Yeah.
We tried to go to an awesome Sushi joint,
we ended up back at another good one.
But yeah,
there was a line,
any line,
fuck all that.
I'm over lines for restaurants,
America,
man,
the same Russia.
I'm not doing that anymore.
Yeah,
wait,
no fucking bread lines.
I don't care what it is,
man.
There's all these,
you know,
what is it like Franklins barbecue in Austin or like Hattie's and in uh,
Nashville and every time I go there,
like you got to go this place and then there's like an hour wait outside and I'm
like,
we'll go somewhere else,
but this is awesome.
I'm like,
no,
it's not that awesome.
Same thing happened in Philly.
I went to some uh,
cheese steak place and it wasn't the two big ones.
It wasn't Geno's or the one,
whatever it is across the street.
And the same thing.
It's like a waited like 45 minutes or an hour to get a cheese steak.
And then my friend was like,
how is it?
I'm like,
it's a good cheese steak.
I mean,
it tastes like a good one.
Well what,
it tastes better if you now have to wait in line for 45.
Of course,
of course men.
Uh,
I dunno,
I'm just not into it.
I'm not into it either.
Um,
I don't,
I don't have that kind of time or patience for waiting for the patients for it.
I just go somewhere and we went down the street.
Something I can do to just get this line.
No.
Okay.
I'll go somewhere else.
Well,
they always lie to you too and they're like,
oh,
it goes by fast.
Put your name on it.
No,
it never does.
When you're standing and you're,
I know.
Soon as I saw that line outside for that,
for lunch at that place,
I was like,
go fuck yourself man.
No Fuck Outta here with that shit.
Get the fuck.
Where did we see douchebag?
Hedge Fund guy that was there.
No,
but where did we see him again?
Afterwards at store where I bought that shirt for a little jeans where he was
walking out and we know that was Starbucks stocks.
We took a pee there.
Yeah.
Took a pee break.
That dude.
Yeah,
there was so fun.
There's like a group of the cast of billions like these days,
coast douche bags,
like white shoes.
And I it,
I'm starting to get that sadness,
that a series ending sadness.
I know there's like five,
six episodes left and I'm already like,
now did they,
are they making a season three or is it,
I don't know anything about it.
Let's see.
Let's see if a billion,
let's see if there's a season three and outs confirmed.
Yes.
It will air next year though.
Fuck mother offer at when?
When next year.
It doesn't say it takes so long to make my favorite TV shows.
I wish to see it now.
This furthers my argument for starting a show.
Well after it it's a,
yeah.
Then you can binge the 10 seasons.
I know.
Like I'm into the soprano's dude.
Yeah,
I like it.
Fucking like it.
Like that.
It's a Zombie show.
I'm onboard.
Yeah.
Walking dead.
Game of Thrones.
Yeah.
Um,
but what we saw at the Sushi bar was interesting.
Uh,
we saw a lot of hungry tits out and about yesterday.
No Bra,
no bra,
which is French.
Yeah,
Teddy.
Just out.
Just little titties does dine,
eat nine would be fed and they were just licking their lips like,
do you got something for me?
And I tried to put my chopsticks up to her tits.
I was like,
you want me to give a little piece stupid?
She was like,
no,
I feed him when I can.
But she was a French girl.
So that's kind of
[inaudible] Blah evens all we invented Lusia Gla.
No Joy.
It's so weird.
The uh,
euros do that.
They like their tits to jiggle around,
but only if you got small,
hungry tits.
Can you do no fuck.
Yeah,
you can't go braless when you got big quadruple d slot wife tits like mine,
there's no fucking way.
Well you just look,
then you look crazy because my hangar old hangers out.
Yeah.
You'll look real.
Real crazy.
Yeah.
Cause aim,
they move a lot more than,
uh,
you know those little French tits dude,
of course.
Um,
let's see.
So if you're okay,
if you're listening to a moment,
this comes out,
we are in brass balls beach tonight.
That's right.
We're doing the podcast live palm,
cat,
Palm Beach County,
and if you're here,
Broward Day,
come see us.
We're at the brass balls beach improv.
We're doing a live podcast and we're going to do a course,
a a meet and greet with everybody.
Afterwards we'll be hanging out.
Come see us.
Come say hi.
I might have a glass of Chardonnay.
Oh Man,
are listening.
I also would love to tell you that I have a huge leg of my tour coming up.
I'm going to rub,
rub,
rub in Lincoln,
Nebraska,
Midwest city,
Oklahoma,
and Springfield,
Missouri.
Uh,
that's my lead up week to my special taping week,
which I will start
September 13 in Braya September 14th at the Oakland,
excuse me,
the Fox theater in Oakland,
California.
And then I'm shooting two shows in Denver,
Colorado at the paramount.
September 16th.
I couldn't be more excited.
Uh,
from there,
the tour continues.
I have a bunch of cities@thomsonreuters.com slash tour.
Please check out the site and you can see him coming to everywhere from Albany
to Portland,
Maine,
Toronto,
Ann Arbor,
Indi St Louis,
tits.
Farct go San Antonio,
Austin and keeps going.
New York City,
Buffalo,
La Phoenix SMURF Lau.
And we're doing another podcast live in Irvine,
sperm vine.
October the eighth,
Irvine,
California.
At the Improv tickets.
Did Not transfer if you had them before.
So you have to get new ones.
Jean Oh,
is a title we had for your special at Denver coming on you Denver.
Um,
I don't know man.
Yesterday we came up with,
I relate a few mile high km that
okay.
All right.
Uh,
September 22nd and 23rd St Louis Tetes,
Missouri at the Helium Comedy Club.
October 3rd,
Nashville.
What does Nashville,
Nashville,
Tennessee.
Xannies comedy club.
October 4th sharklet north cow.
Cackle Laka as you say,
as if that's a real thing.
Real comedies on.
And then with you October 8th at why IMH lies in sperm vine.
Yeah,
very excited.
Very amazed.
Excite Amaz guys check out that steep brow as well.
I take listener emails this week.
Uh,
a girl wrote in asking whether or not she should reveal that her cousin is
actually her biological sister.
Whoa.
Jerry Springer stuff.
It's pretty exciting.
Yeah.
Her cousin is her biological sister and the cousin doesn't know it.
They don't know it.
No one person that knows is her mother.
It's too much.
I know.
It's awesome.
All right,
well there you go.
That's deep bro.
Check it out.
Yeah.
Oh mm.
Uh,
yeah.
That's it,
right?
That's all we have for now.
You're one to always
boast and brag about your h two o consumption.
Meanwhile,
you,
you tear those down who hydrate in a different manner.
Science has something to say to you.
Sure.
To wake you up.
New Research says coffee,
dehydrate you please.
Researchers from Birmingham University saving perhaps of the drink are hydrating
as water
bullshit.
Listen,
I don't know what kind of fake news propaganda this is.
News breaker,
whatever that is.
Hi.
Effect of caffeine is balanced by the amount of water and the drink.
Something that wasn't taken into account the last time done in 1928 Jesus.
Now the current study compared managed,
drank four months of coffee versus four months of water for three days while
eating the same food.
The results,
a guilt free cup of morning Joe for the rest of us.
Whatever.
Just still drink water.
Of course propaganda.
About 1.6 billion cups of coffee are consumed worldwide every day.
[inaudible] this study is sure to please the masses,
but researchers still suggest balancing each cup with a glass of water.
Right?
See the why do they still,
why would they still suggest that?
Because they have to watch their backs.
You have to make sure.
Exactly.
Because they know this is not conclusive.
This is not a conclusive study.
They're still saying drink water in addition to otherwise they would just sell
you a bottle is a coffee like this and they,
and then they give marathon runners bottles of coffee.
So there you go.
It's fine.
You can drink your coffee.
All right.
How come I'm so thirsty when I drink coffee though.
Um,
I think it's cause you were retarded.
Oh,
then that happens where it goes down weird and then you're thirsty.
It's because your chromosomes are all stupid.
Let's go through some special,
some title specials for you.
I'd go retarded.
How might that was?
My teeth are still yellow right here.
There's still yellow.
That's a good one.
Write it down.
Not Personality Champ.
No.
How about retarded comic?
I like that.
Yeah.
How about we had some great ones yesterday.
No,
I know.
That's how it goes.
They just suck on it.
Denver,
come,
come on my sock or something like that.
Mm.
Come on my balls.
Balls full of cum.
Yeah.
Now that's a catchy title.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
we had some great ones.
Cheesy jokes.
I forget it.
Just forget this.
You forget if you forget them all too though.
I know.
I forgot them.
Let's do some now.
What are you leaning towards?
Come beard.
No.
What,
what rob.
Rob.
Yeah.
I liked that one.
Sharpening the knife.
Just glassing.
Just glassine that's a good title actually.
No,
it doesn't matter that my special,
my hours.
Not about that.
Like comedy titles.
You want those two word in three word titles.
You know,
those are the ones,
the,
those are the best ones.
Plus it's a shout out to all your mind out to the podcast.
It's um,
it's great key art for the,
like the,
the cover and stuff.
It's like a,
he's hold and like kind of coyly.
It's stupid.
And it,
but that's the thing.
It can be stupid.
It's a standup special.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be silly.
I mean you could call it sharpening the knife.
I like that too.
Yeah,
that's actually a really good,
uh,
it's,
but it,
you know,
it's obviously a joke.
I mean,
you can take that seriously and be like,
I'm sharpening my joke instrument.
I'm killing it or something silly.
Yeah.
But I mean jokingly sharpening the knife is funny.
I think it should be the title and I am sharpening the knife,
you know?
Uh,
metaphorically metaphor.
Right.
So what about um,
uh,
jokes for Moose Soup?
[inaudible]
what about fuck me in my ass,
man.
Hey,
that's a title.
It's my favorite.
What about Thomson Garage then the title is Tom or black.
That's good.
You get that.
Then you get different audience.
That demographic's changed a little bit.
Yup.
How about,
um,
how about 50 inches?
Press nine inches and price changes.
Press nine inches and
yeah.
How does my asshole smell?
That's a good title.
Nailed it.
How does my asshole smell?
Huh?
Put the hot in there.
Uh,
not all Nazis are bad.
They would.
What about the other side guys?
That could be,
that could be a title.
It's a funny title.
Nazi's are bad.
Yeah.
How about instead of Neo Nazis,
it's nifty Nazis or something like that.
Like how about this?
Something Nazis.
I'm Sigora silly Nazi.
Silly Nazi.
That's a pretty funny title.
Yeah.
That's just a fun one.
Or just tell him,
Hey Hitler.
Yeah,
I mean that's a whole new,
you're really,
you're really not even the net for the,
I think the conversation would go with the breaking it down.
Like,
so here's what I want to do.
They're like,
no,
we don't get it.
It's like a shadow.
You don't get it.
You get all aggressive and they're like,
oh,
it's not really about Hitler.
It's about this girl in the video about my list you guys are doing.
How about I like that.
You're doing good.
Doing good.
Well,
I wanted to call mine.
Good job.
And they weren't.
They wouldn't go for that
or you guys are doing good.
You're doing good.
Yeah.
Oh,
how about this?
How about this Tom?
Sigora what's your pronoun?
I like what's Your Pronoun?
But see that would work better for you.
What's your photo?
Oh yeah,
cause I have non binary stuff.
How many?
A lot of nasty emails on that.
Definitely.
I don't think you're ready for it.
No idea.
I'm really good.
Oh Man.
Tom Segura Nasty.
Nasty as hell.
How about
running the industry?
Uh,
you like that.
That's good for you.
Yeah.
You like that Kinda,
you know Sassy Lingo.
Yeah.
That's good.
We're going to keep them motherfuckers out.
Trap 99 build that wall.
Build that wall.
There you go.
God.
Here you go.
That'd be the last special I ever had.
Oh my God.
Could you imagine that wall?
My Life?
Yeah.
Oh boy.
I'm telling you.
I actually,
this is a good title.
Just glass and just glass is a great title.
Yeah.
I love you guys.
Glassine right in and let us know if you think that's a good time.
We should put up a poll actually.
Yes.
How about
my ass?
My ass?
Yeah.
What about it's not sexual or it's just like the gaze.
Just like the gay.
How about it's only smells.
It's only smells.
That's actually really good.
Pretty good.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I Dunno.
What about,
would you marry your mom?
Would you marry your mom?
Would you ever date your mom asked him,
will you ever date your mom?
It's a good title.
I would date my mom.
That's my title.
I asked,
I asked.
It's just like the gays
for foreign obviously a definitely good comedy title for real is when,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That's a good time comedy title cause you're talking to me.
You know it has to be a play on it though.
Yeah.
Like you know,
uh,
I don't know what the play is,
but they can't just give a fuck about none of
that was the best one.
Ms. Powell was in here and you played for and she's like,
you always do the best you make fun of black men.
No,
she goes,
I love your imitation.
Yeah.
Cause your invitation of pipe that goes,
not an invitation.
Yeah.
Hang on.
So disrespectful.
All my Kolbe Stroud go oral or come for arc.
How about Ooh,
I got another,
a good one.
Are you ready for it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Hold on.
This is a,
uh,
I don't see it.
This would be so good.
Fuck.
You guys are doing it's rub,
rub,
rub.
No,
I think it's just glassing are feeling what?
You feel me all the time out and I was that my me.
You don't tell me if you know what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
That's a good one.
It's funny.
Yeah.
Eh.
How about Oh,
here it is.
Ready?
Yeah.
This is the title comes up on your screen.
Tom Cigarette
man.
I am the king of in province for,
for you
the king of Improv.
Improv.
I like that.
About the king of standup.
The king of,
yeah.
See I could be the king of Con,
but then there's the kings of comedy.
Awesome title.
So it's a brand.
It's so brash and I would get so much hate people like a cap of Levy.
So crazy title.
You think we actually have to pause for a moment.
Press pause.
We have to press pause with her to cat cvas and
their business call.
Yeah.
Do our little business call.
We'll be right back.
Well,
you won't even know.
I don't know what I'm saying.
We'll be right back.
Welcome back.
We're back.
We'll have seven.
Seven.
Okay.
Some interesting emails came in.
Drew birds are hot farts smell year.
Oh Wow.
Hey Mama
TV last night came across a question that needs immediate attention.
I was on the couch next to my nonbinary spouse when I had two f a r t upon
release I noticed the started only hot nature of the gas.
Yeah.
It happened to be particularly smelly and I pondered what the connection of heat
to smell is.
Our farts that come out hot,
more smelly and what causes the heat sensation.
Wow.
I knew I had to come to my main mommy's to get to the bottom of this.
I will see you at wet balls beach for the live show.
I called ahead to make sure that have moose soup ready.
Well.
Interesting question and I feel like medically we need to,
I think we need to reach out to a professional to get real guidance on that.
But I definitely have had that thought like,
wow,
this is hot and it doesn't smell good.
No.
And I think,
I think you're right that the hot farts do tend to as be smellier.
Yeah.
And I think it has something to do with the molecules being heated up.
F a.
R.
T it's you know why?
Okay,
think about it.
When you cook food in the microwave,
the molecules bounce around and the smell emanates right because of the heat.
But why is it hot and why is it coming out of your head that now?
That's another question that,
I mean,
why are there hot farts?
I Dunno.
I feel like this is one of the great life aren't great mysteries of life.
Like do twins have identical dicks?
This one of those questions of why are they hotter?
I Dunno.
So far on the identical Dicks,
we've kind of come to the conclusion
that identical twins seemed to have identical dicks,
but fraternal twins don't necessarily,
which makes sense.
Yeah.
Oh yes,
yes.
We were back to this.
This is how I'm straight.
Yeah,
so let's,
let's go down the list of things that give you hot parts.
Number one,
Broccoli.
Yeah,
a dried apricots.
Give me hot farts.
Okay.
Ethnic food,
Kimchi.
[inaudible] now you know what they have in common.
What high fiber content.
There you go.
Bell peppers.
High fiber fiber makes it hotter now.
But why this fiber translate to heat in your bum hall?
It's a great question.
Why is it a five?
I don't know.
These are,
there's a lot of mysteries out there that you know,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Okay,
so if you're a medical professional,
let us know why side we parts are hot wire farts,
sometimes hot.
Why our heart hot farts?
Smellier while we decide I know why they're smelly or because they're hot and
therefore the molecules are bouncing around.
That's your theory.
You said,
I know that's what creates smell,
but you're saying you don't know that for sure,
right?
Theory.
Yeah,
but I'm saying like,
let's get it confirmed.
Seventh Grade Science Knowledge.
That's good.
A confirmed man.
God,
I never,
and isn't that amazing?
You go through your whole life just accepting that as a given and then one day
somebody just challenges your whole way of being.
You feel that he'd come on,
you're like,
oh man.
And if you're in public,
he would look around like,
oh,
this is going to hit somebody he didn't know before.
You know before when that,
when that gas is cooking,
when it's really hot stoves on,
Ooh,
it's going to stink.
Like yesterday I was eating a bowl of my own soup,
not Moosup,
just veggie soup and I thought I shouldn't have a second bowl because it's going
to make a lot of hot farts and I didn't want to punish you and bed.
And then there's like,
you know with noisy ones it's here.
There you go.
Like this is loud maybe.
And then you go,
oh,
nothing could go either way.
It could go either way.
Sometimes I'll even let out a fart during a massage.
How sphincter control if the control is there.
Yeah,
because I know like it can't smell that like that bad sometimes,
but sometimes can't you feel that this one would smell if I let it out?
Yes.
Those are the hot ones.
You know they're hot before they even come out until you're like,
this is gonna be a hot.
Sometimes you go,
Ooh,
that'd be
amazing.
Cause you feel the,
the Gurgles,
you know the cramping that goes with it.
Yeah.
Dear Mommy's,
in recent podcasts you were playing the clip of the mother and son who were
dating their behavior can be explained by genetic sexual attraction.
GSA is an overwhelming sexual attraction that may develop between clothes bought
blood relatives who first meet as adults and that could very well happen.
Could have been what happened to those two.
Right.
Had that,
that thing of like,
uh,
seemed like they didn't grow up together.
She didn't raise him.
She may have birthed him.
It didn't raise,
have a college friend of mine was adopted as a baby.
After College.
He sought out her birth family and found her mother and two brothers during
counseling.
She was warned about genetic sexual attraction is thought that occurs because
the normal sibling,
parental bonding doesn't occur during childhood.
Supposedly.
It's rare.
I'm beginning to wonder Ben,
I think that's a really interesting email.
Absolutely.
So what's happening is like,
because of the lack of that bonding between siblings and or parents,
something that happens when you meet them for the first time as adults and
you're,
you're trying to,
you know,
figure out or,
or,
or let the bonding occur and it turns into sexual energy because it's not,
it's not dispersed naturally through raising that is fast.
You know what I read today,
my shrink's office is why people are attracted to each other.
Just like the gays,
like sexual partners,
not related people.
And they say that you're attracted to people that look like you.
Really?
Yeah.
Like it's unconscious where they have similar features.
And if you look at the two of us,
both of us have big lips.
I have beautiful eyes.
Years are kind of bulging like faiths,
but we have similar,
uh,
you know,
the dark baggy under eye circles and I mean,
our kid looks you have a nice penis,
your penis is enormous.
Like,
yeah.
They say that you look for people that look similar to you,
but there's a lot of people that consciously,
I don't know.
I don't,
yeah,
of course.
Of course there are.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
But of course,
I wonder about that.
Do you think we saw each other out for that?
It's unconscious.
I think you,
you connect sexually with people too,
when like in a more deep way now,
obviously like just a one night stand way.
But when you're attracted to somebody that you share it psychological things
with Oh yeah.
I think it's,
it's a total meshing of our unconscious is bullshit or issues.
Definitely.
It's all,
it's all mommy did that I see clearly now.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
You and I,
that's why we work well together.
I think there really,
it was just like the case we really,
we have such a good unconscious pairing.
Yeah.
It's our issues that we kind of Meld together nicely.
You know,
when it comes to dad boners um,
a lot of people,
we've,
we've pointed out that there's two types of dad boners there's,
there's the real,
the true dad boner who's excited for something and not excitable.
Then we call it the justified dad boner.
And that is somebody who's super excited about something.
But there's reason to be and that one is,
is,
uh,
is there's more reason to celebrate and we shouldn't,
you know,
those are the ones that we not along to like,
yeah,
I see why you're this excited.
We have one of those today.
It is a dad boner for sure,
but it's justified as Boehner is there for a reason.
And I would be this excited to check out what this boner does.
He's,
he's doing like Frisbee golf and a Frisbee Golf,
throwing a Frisbee on the course,
trying to get to a target.
But he's really,
I mean this is,
I dunno how far away you would say this is that Frisbee Shit.
Look at this.
Look how far that white people are,
his recipes.
It feels like it's fucking 80 yards away.
It so far,
far away then
that's a real fucking of that.
That was a really good throw.
I mean look how far away that is.
I know why people love playing Frisbee,
don't they?
They have like ultimate frisbee leagues and Dumb Shit like that around fucking
Frisbee and your white people too much time on their hands.
You know they either march with the Tiki torches or throw a frisbee.
Right.
You got to keep white people occupied.
He was real excited.
But I understand that level cause I mean that is,
look how far away this
feels like it's a God damn football field.
Oh my God.
He imagine like how much better it is that it's recorded to that guy.
Otherwise you just like,
remember when I did that and do it right?
Well whatever dad did you really do it?
What?
Yeah,
I didn't know people even did this.
this is so weird.
The frisbee golf.
Yeah,
that's a fucking course.
Like two of the most boring sports put together in one thing.
I know I'm trying,
I wish I could get into golf.
It just takes too long to play.
It's like a four hour commitment.
That's half your fucking day.
A lot of times.
How do people have time for
golf?
I want to have,
I dunno,
I've,
I fantasize about about being in the culture of it just because I feel like
it's,
it'd be,
it's fun way to unwind.
It's a,
it's hanging out basically is what it is.
Yeah.
You're hanging out with your friends.
I don't know if I could get into it though.
I did it.
Uh,
20 years ago.
I played regularly for one summer,
so the summer after my freshman year in college,
my parents lived on a golf course,
so I came home.
I had a job where I could set my own hours,
so I would just,
I just took up golf and I was taking lessons and that was playing,
playing pretty regularly and I enjoyed it.
You or are you good at it?
I got to,
I got to respectable.
I got to the point where my great fear,
it's almost like flying with the,
with our son was that when I was,
when I was playing before that and when I was on the driving range,
I was terrible and I was embarrassed to join,
uh,
like a twosome they call it or a for something like a group to play golf.
And then I played so much that summer that by like midsummer,
I was,
I could play a respectable round meeting.
I,
you know,
I could hit the ball without it,
uh,
hooking or shanking and,
and,
and error going four feet instead of,
you know,
a hundred yards.
So I just got,
I got a,
uh,
I mean I was not good,
but I was enough.
I was decent enough to join a game of golf and play and,
and again there.
Yeah,
yeah.
But then I went back to college and I remember I didn't play for like six months
or something.
And then somebody who was like,
you don't play golf today.
I go,
sure.
We went out there and men,
I shit the bed so bad.
And then it just,
it was a discouraging.
It was just,
you know,
I was like,
oh,
I suck at this.
I said,
well,
it's a,
it's an older,
isn't it an kind of an older guys?
I mean,
it's definitely a bigger,
for sure amongst older guys,
but it is like a,
you know,
the thing that I like about golf is that it takes you to destinations.
In other words,
you'll end up checking out places you wouldn't because it has a golf as a
destination and it's the hang.
It's like,
oh,
I could call somebody up.
What are you doing today?
Let's go play golf up,
go there and broke down.
Now is there any athletic ability
required to play golf?
Can you stand right,
that's what I'm saying.
Those guys don't really look good.
Well,
it's not a word unless her tiger,
you know,
I mean,
it's not,
you can be a piece of shit and you can be a fat fuck like bowling too.
It doesn't require it.
Do you have that joke that joke about it?
What is it that the term,
the triple crown of Lazy Darts.
Bowling and golf.
Yeah.
Bowling,
I forget.
You can be a fat fuck and still be in that.
You can,
yeah.
No,
I wouldn't do it.
It's not like a sport that I'm picking you up to stay in shape.
It was yet.
I think that's the problem.
That's it.
I mean,
even theoretically with golf for me is that it requires no physical ability.
It's a huge time suck.
You're out in the sun,
get you fucking burned.
It's expensive.
The reason that it's not for me,
the people chase the dragon though.
Cause that is what happens is it's,
it's very,
it's difficult,
right?
It takes an incredible amount of skill and so you have a good shot or a good
hole and then you go,
oh,
that was fucking awesome.
Like I had a Birdie,
you know,
I went under par.
I,
I did really well.
That and then that fee,
that's the feeling you're chasing,
right?
Doing well.
I like the,
I like miniature golf.
It's also very challenging.
Yes.
That's fun.
Yeah,
it's fun.
Yeah.
That's good to do that.
I don't think he would like actual golf.
I've only ever,
no,
I've never played.
But you never know.
You actually never,
you could go out into a driving range,
have somebody show you how to do it,
and then you could just,
you could be somebody that has like a natural skill.
I doubtful.
Okay.
No,
it's definitely doubtful.
Hold on.
I'm deaf in one ear here.
Brace yourself.
Fix it.
Let's see.
Hello?
Hello.
Still Fuck.
OCTA.
No,
so for cocktail,
it's weird.
It just happened when we came back from our call and it's definitely not here.
It's in.
I'll fix it later.
It's fine for now.
Well,
I dunno,
we'll I pick up golf.
I don't know.
Maybe when you're all,
I mean I get it when you're old because then you got,
if you're retired,
perfect,
you got nothing but time hanging out with your friends.
You don't need to have a lot of ability.
It's definitely an older man's gentlemen,
Jasmine Jackson,
my Cantonese boy,
gen to me as a dancer.
Another great blind question came in.
I love these.
I love these so much.
I know,
and it's,
and by the way,
thank you for all the feedback people have been emailing us about our deaf and
blind questions.
That's so fascinating.
Both are fascinated by it,
including us.
Uh,
as a reminder,
if you have a question and answer a clip,
a song,
always email the
g mail account.
It is your mom's podcast@gmail.com.
Don't send it on Facebook,
don't send it to any other address.
Send it to the Gmail account,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com.
And as always,
thank you for messaging,
uh,
us with content,
with clips,
with all that.
You can go to your mom's house podcast at,
uh,
sorry,
your mom's house,
podcast.com.
If you want to check out the site has a youtube links,
links to all the download,
has a link to the store.
We have a bunch of really cool shirts,
merge things that are signed.
Check that out.
And thank you as always for your support.
So here is the question.
You have trouble with that one?
Yeah,
I can hear it crackling in the right.
It's so something's wrong.
And only doing one year and I switched headphones too,
so we'll figure it out later.
Okay.
We'll do blind people masturbate too.
Oh my God.
He's been listening to your educational podcast for quite a while now and I
really appreciate you tackling all these hot button issues.
The major networks are afraid to touch on the topic of blind people.
I couldn't help but wonder about their porn preferences.
Do Blind people just listen to the audio?
Why they pound off an or a DJ?
The bean,
I know they make movies and TV with audio description for the blind that
describes what is happening over top of the audio.
Do they make porn for the blind and the describes what is happening in the
scene.
Also,
I don't know anyone that watches the full scene.
It doesn't just skip around to the good parts.
How to blind people.
Skip to just the bits they want to hear.
I anxiously await your answer.
Thank you for keeping me in the know every Wednesday.
Tyler from Cincinnati.
Really great question,
Tyler.
Um,
first of all,
we actually did play a,
a blind porn chlorine for the blind.
So somebody describes it to the blind person,
but he's saying how do,
how do they skip ahead?
I mean,
I guess that's just what they do.
I feel like you did something to me now.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I got to stop this.
Okay.
Now it's back to normal.
It is happening.
I Dunno.
Well,
I'm deaf in one ear.
You're definitely year.
Okay.
Did you try moving your mic cable?
Mm.
Cause when I don't unplug it moving and then how would I move it if,
I don't know,
cause I moved mine,
it popped back in.
Oh,
that's okay.
I'll figure it out later.
I can survive.
Um,
let's see.
I feel like that,
did we,
can I tell you one thing that our trainer told me that is very,
it's been upsetting me.
She says she has a friend who has the toto washlet.
Yeah.
But her model flushes itself.
When she told me they have a,
that flushes for
them.
I felt like we were the poorest people ever.
Yeah.
I know.
We don't have that.
I feel like a peasant now.
So the toilet flushes by itself.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's um,
not what we have.
No,
I have to flush and I feel like I'm a poor person.
Why don't we have that?
Yeah.
What have you done today?
What did you do to this?
Why did you ruin everything today?
Why did you do that?
I did nothing.
You did?
I did nothing to your rigid.
God dammit.
What's wrong now I'm hearing weird shit.
Now that you keep fucking with the headphone Jack Abusive.
You are.
How has that abusive so mean?
How was that mean?
I get like a gag that day.
That is accurate.
That's your,
you're the Goonies lady right now.
Ah,
man.
You ruin.
I know it's mine.
It's crackling too.
I didn't read it.
All right,
so let's see if this is a,
something that could play a
porn for the blind.
I don't know if this is a real one or not.
To engaging in various sexual scenarios.
Flash in quick succession.
Yeah.
So somebody dictating to her,
kneeling on the green,
gray shag carpet,
walking onto a sties,
giving him a round of blow job.
There you go.
And then kisses the head of his penis as he rubs it along.
Her left breast is now standing over her as she lays on the cushions of a dark
green couch holding up her pants,
pants between them.
So it's morning for the blind.
I,
that's it.
How do you fast forward through that?
You just fast,
fast forward.
Yeah.
You just scroll forward and then usually like,
well,
what's going on now?
You know,
10 of them.
Both of them.
She's fingering herself.
Oh my God.
This coming on her ass.
There you go.
That's a part I wanted.
Oh,
I mean that's it.
That's exactly what we were talking about.
Right.
Scrolls forward.
What's that?
So good job.
Good job making that porn.
But I guess that is,
you know,
that is real porn or,
yeah,
I guess so.
I guess they have to use their imagination and
yeah.
Otherwise you've just listened to the Yoh ruins porn a lot.
It's the porn music.
Yeah.
I think what ruins porn for me too is all the scenarios and the bill that like
just go to the bag and you like that guns out.
Just get in there.
I mean,
I'm not going to watch plot.
Are you not at all watch?
No.
Sometimes I don't care.
You don't.
You don't like a,
Oh shit,
I missed the bus.
No,
I mean it's not like I'm,
I'm really pleased with myself when I'm doing that,
so I'm like,
just get in,
get out.
What you're upset with yourself for?
Just checking it out.
Well,
I'm not,
I'm not in a good place if I'm new.
You know what I mean?
Wow.
Really that,
that's,
that's really harsh though on yourself,
is it?
I think so.
To be like I'm not in a good place.
Well,
I guess I just want to get in and get out.
I'm not really looking to spend a lot of time in that neighbor.
How much time did you,
did you try to spend there when you do go there?
I don't know.
I don't time myself,
but I definitely don't want to like lounge and put my feet up and really,
and the terror that I thought that there was the only way to do that.
I thought it was like get comfortable.
You have your drink,
you have something to eat.
You're like,
you know,
let's get,
just try and get through 30 of these and like the most,
I don't have that kind of time.
I know I don't do that.
Okay.
Not Interested and usually it's such a vulgar area.
Even in the neighborhood is so dark.
No stills are like cream pie,
double fist,
anal.
Finally.
I don't want any of that.
Just give me normal.
Whereas like the normal section,
normal section,
shut that shit down.
I don't want to see that at all.
I want to see what do you like prolapsed Colin's six Dick's stuff.
That's just crazy.
Yeah,
it's too crazy.
That's what I'm saying.
I think it's not that I'm so ashamed myself.
More so that the neighbor,
it's so crazy just to find like an relatively tame clip.
Do you know what I mean?
I'm not into the six guy prolapse.
Colin,
why anal fisting double fuck t you know what's wrong with you?
It just normal stuff's exciting enough for me personally.
Just guy,
girl,
just five,
five portering guys and two girls.
12 strong and durable.
Resistant to terrorists.
Drape,
swell resistant.
Her Nan is a type of 12th in jeans.
The smoother side she used as the front.
Typically the vertical warp behinds are dyed blue and the weft yarn is left
natural.
There you go.
See if it didn't have denim,
I'd be much more board.
Yeah,
but we have a little denim.
So Denim is the right way to go.
Um,
how you feel about this?
Hello everybody,
this chick in Lawrence today.
I'm going to do a urine for the first time.
First Time.
Oh,
we've had her before.
She Drinks Her pee to help her fight colds.
Yeah.
Yeah,
she does.
And we've,
we've shown her doing it before.
She looks
better than during the day.
I have collected my urine
and it just poured one court into my animal bucket above me.
Neat.
Oh,
she does actually.
Look,
really,
wait a minute.
This chick has a patriotic count for what talent are we?
It was just her giving herself.
That's what I'm going to hold it for about five minutes to do this video.
Just to document my experience because I'm expecting,
you know,
maybe to be enlightened or have a spiritual and I wanted to have it on camera.
Well cool.
I feel like we did here with a coffee enema.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And she was like,
I'm holding it in.
It's a little painful right now.
I'm loving this.
I don't want our kid fucking pulling on a snake,
pulling his snake.
Okay,
let's go back to the p lady.
This is hilarious.
She's going to get enlightened by putting piss in her ass.
I'm going to lay on my left side and I'm going to hold it for about five minutes
just to document my experience.
So right now I'm just taking some coconut oil and I'm feeling to liberal Kate.
She is so awesome.
I'm also going to lubricate my bottom end.
Oh,
that's right.
She said about him and on the coffee when she's,
it's weird how she's picky about certain words,
but she's putting piss up her butt and her asshole.
Okay,
so I'm waiting on that left side.
I love this shit to insert the nozzle right now.
You know?
It makes me,
it makes me,
why is she a couple deep breaths?
She's really into torturing herself.
This broad
stop it.
I'm going to allow the urine to enter my colon doing this.
I'm going to try to hold it for about five minutes.
Okay.
I'm opening the clamp now.
Why are you doing this to yourself?
Oh,
noticing.
Okay.
What is she noticing?
How horrible this feels.
Remember I was going to try to get someone to piss on my balls.
I don't remember.
You know what,
how long?
Four minutes is.
Remember when Lgi again,
but remember when Lj and I were riding the train in the mall?
That was four minutes.
That's an eternity piss in your asshole dude.
And you know how much it hurts to have.
Have you ever had like anything pushed up your belt like an enema or anything?
One time I put a suppository in my butt.
Just that suppository.
It's not fun,
Dude.
It fucking hurts.
This chick is crazy.
Opening the clamp again.
Can't puppy up.
They're
just wrong with this person.
I'm having a little bit of leakage and I don't,
I don't know why.
It's leaking out a little bit though.
Stop doing this.
Stop it.
This chick likes to hurt her.
So when I open the clamp,
pull one more time.
Please.
Don't you know what?
I was
starting to have this purple vision.
Um,
it was drugs.
No,
go to her patron account.
Please donate and,
and,
and then,
right?
Keep putting up your ass.
Keep picking up your own asshole.
Rain,
Florence.
Now here's the thing though.
Gene,
10,000 more people
coming together.
Oh Man.
You know what though?
When you put something up your bum,
it absorbs immediately into your bloodstream.
You know that,
right?
Yeah.
So I don't even know if it's okay to put urine in your bung hole because then
there's toxins in urine that are going right into her bloodstream.
There's a reason it's it's waste.
I just picked up on something that I was not expecting and that is what she said
right now.
We might look,
be looking at the solution this country needs.
This might be the Martin Luther King Jr of this era,
and don't attack me for saying so what I want to point out is that when she
pissed in her own ass,
she had a vision of all of us coming together and maybe
10,000 more people
coming together.
Oh,
is this in response to Charlottesville and support and support me.
have you?
Oh,
I mean,
maybe this is the answer to this.
This divide in our country right now is a,
what if we all did urine enemas?
A thought provoking suggestion.
And what if somebody like Donald Trump said it?
What if our pricing is like and want you to take an enema and want you to put it
in your ass?
I want you to Piss Him pee in your butt and in your own bud by rain.
Florence rain tried.
It goes tremendous feelings.
She felt so good.
Democrats and Republicans and independents alike.
I'm opening the clamp again.
Wow.
Oh Wow.
Oh my goodness.
Let her know.
I almost just want to cry.
Wow.
Geez.
Maybe we should give this a try.
Think so.
I'm having a little bit of a sensation and my botox reason region.
Yeah.
Those are toxins.
Might just be because they,
the urine is a little bit cold.
Yeah.
There might be other reasons.
Are there any health benefits to putting urine in your,
in your bom?
Um,
I dunno,
it was a followup on this or something like that.
It's enlightenment.
What a psycho.
Yeah.
Kinds of crazy.
Can't be medically sound.
No,
I mean it's waste.
You're essentially putting,
it's like putting poop.
It would be like taking a shit and then making the shit liquid and then putting
the shit up your own.
But that's kind of,
I mean,
urine is waste.
It is waste.
It's not toxic
and,
and horrific for you as a shit.
No,
you can drink your own urine if you let it sit.
It will separate and then you can drink the clearer part of it.
I read that in a book.
Oh No,
you should drink all of it.
That's what I do.
It's delicious.
Um,
we also had an email from Dan.
You want to hear what he has to say?
Of course.
Mommy's.
I just wanted to let you know him.
I had my third dump of the day already and it's only 12:30 PM normally I poop
once or twice a day.
I'm wondering,
do you think this could be a side effect of over hydration?
I was wondering if this ever happens to Tom in particular.
Keeps me,
is the water champ top dogs is vice might be needed as well.
Dan from San Jose.
Oh,
look at Christina.
Trying to show off in the home stretch when it doesn't count.
I think it's indicative of,
yes,
your water intake.
It could be something like that.
Fiber or an irritation.
Now you didn't tell us what number you're taking.
Is it Loosey Goosey?
Are we talking,
you know,
is it,
is it a little bit of a slider?
What is it?
Yeah,
we don't know detail.
You're Brown,
but I would feel three by 1230 is a lot.
That's pretty aggressive.
It sounds sick.
I mean who knows if he sent another email after that and it was like,
oh,
it's 6:00 PM I've taken six shifts.
You have diarrhea and that's what I'm saying.
This guy could be just sick.
Um,
so Christina shot a special,
uh,
in June.
Some of you were there and um,
you know,
she'll have an announcement about it soon in the lead up to it.
She's been doing a lot of press.
It's getting things ready for it to come out.
I don't want to hear this here is Christina talking about her news?
Special works cited this show everybody.
It's up lizard.
Yeah,
we'll be fine.
You've got an ear.
Be Pack.
The dude with the cameras.
Scared.
Do Mac.
We're excited about
my hair is a little darker.
Yeah.
And it's a different outfit than I normally see you in.
Nick,
do you comprehend?
I moved from California,
California.
You don't know.
I'm in California in 2012 my parents gave me
and
my dog.
I bought him a dog.
Why do you think,
what do you think's going on with her?
Sorry,
what did,
what were you thinking there?
Why are you telling this guy about your dog and your well,
I mean,
look,
I was excited about the special.
I had a little too many to celebrate and just tried to give him,
get an interview and didn't come out right.
Not like some pit bull dog run around
and that little girl,
we'll be in the hospital tonight,
but it looks like she's going to be okay.
As far as any charges or anything.
Nothing's pending at this point.
There's still needs to be further investigation and this is actually the
homeowner.
We're going to,
we're going to talk,
we're going to toss it back to you in the studio.
Randy,
don't want to add.
He's a pro.
Yeah.
Yell it together.
That's like a heckler.
It's like when you're doing your show and some drug assholes trying to up.
You're fine.
Any reports on any dogs being loose from my house or um,
loose and running around or have,
there is one.
There was a dog fight.
I got rid of it.
One dog.
This lady needs the whistle.
The whistle.
Blow the whistle.
She does need the whistle dog whistle.
That should win.
Lose or dog.
Yeah.
Uh,
you use the code word mom.
She should get that.
Can we,
can we find her,
you think and tell her about it?
Here's,
ah,
man,
this is you.
This is you.
I moved from California.
Oh,
there you are.
How's that not you?
I didn't say it wasn't.
Yeah,
I told that I had a little too much,
too much to drink.
That happens.
That shouldn't,
I shouldn't have talked to that guy.
I know that that happens.
Um,
let's see.
Dude.
Blow the whistle to
blow the whistle.
Let's see.
I know where our dogs out are right now because of the whistle.
Yeah,
Paulo is all.
Did you do
okay?
Okay.
Why did you do that?
No,
I don't trust you
now.
We're done.
It was so funny.
It's fun.
It's,
I don't trust him.
I put on the headphones.
Run to do
med bones back on.
Come on.
No,
I'll take it down.
No you won't.
Yeah,
I'll take it down.
Take what down.
Clip it down.
Here we go.
Here it is.
There it is.
Over.
Done.
I don't trust you.
I promise it's over.
I promise.
Nope.
Yeah,
it's done.
Yo.
Fuck.
And not listening.
I took it off.
I took,
I put the agent guy on from the train earlier.
He's,
he's back up.
We went to a restaurant and I had them bring
you a slice of birthday cake and you got really,
you did it when I was in the bathroom.
You know,
I tried to avoid as much sugar as I can.
Yeah.
Which this cake is special.
This place where we go,
they have a fantastic cake and you don't want to miss out on it.
You don't have to add the whole thing.
It's hard to resist.
But anyways,
it did say happy birthday and I had a candle in it.
I was like,
you got so mad.
Yeah.
Why do you hate that so much?
I Dunno.
I don't like it.
You don't like people singing you happy birthday or I don't like the attention
that it draws.
Isn't that an interesting,
but yet all you do is get attention for a living,
but I like it in that
moment.
I like it when I'm on stage.
You could control the attention.
I don't like attention offstage.
Right.
I don't need to get a bunch of attention when I walk into a room,
know.
All right.
How about bank?
Do you like it when they sing happy birthday?
No,
I do not.
I don't like surprise parties.
I don't like being sung to,
I don't like a big,
I don't like a big reception.
Like if I walk into a place,
I don't like everybody to say something too.
I don't like that.
You don't want to be like norm from cheers.
No,
I like to fly under the radar.
Yeah,
that's true.
You're kind of low key guy.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I like people to pay attention when I'm up there and that's it.
Yeah.
I agree.
Similar.
Yeah.
I don't mind the happy birthday.
It's embarrassing.
Yeah.
But you're,
you know,
but I've got a great personality and a more festive and more fun.
You're fun.
You just conceded that I'm more fun and more festive and therefore a personality
champ.
Thank you.
We're good.
There's a good case for that.
Um,
oh my God.
Just admitted to the case.
You are.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You are.
If I put these on and I hear Barf,
you're not,
we're going to wrap up.
We got to wrap up.
We've got to wrap up.
Um,
I don't trust you.
Thank you guys for listening.
We're going to have some guests coming up in the next few weeks.
It should be a lot of fun.
And,
um,
I dunno.
I think that's it gene.
That's it.
And we've got a snake in our yard.
We got to go take care of the state.
We've got to get these fucking headphones fixed.
Like don't be so mad,
but we'll,
we'll get it taken care of.
Here is the four oh nine remix lady luck by Chris.
Is it just Chris or does her last name here?
Chris Spence.
Thanks very much.
That's a Jean.
I love you mommy.
Bye.
Mommy.
Go ahead.
But you can smell really.
Do you want me to touch?
We're on the brink of civil war in this country
Mafia.
Yeah,
yeah.